mon père était gardien de phare et ma
mère était reine mais la vie a le don de
rapprocher les êtres tu finiras
peut-être une homo dabo jours
viens voir qui arthur qui parle ou
poissy
c'est moi
qui ont fait de moi ce que je suis
[Musique]
mais si on monte à bord
je te trouve enfin son demi-frère le roi
or me va déclarer la guerre au monde de
la surface
il n'y a qu'une seule façon de sauver la
paix tu dois prendre ta place de roi
légitime
crois moi j'ai rien à voir - tu
réfléchis avant d'agir et mieux tu agis
génial ton discours d'encouragement trop
motivant je te conseille de bien tu as
touché
[Musique]
te voilà de retour chez toi
du monde surface
pour ne disputer le trône
moi je dirais pour te botter les fesses
[Musique]
voilà un chef je suis venu parce que je
n'avais pas le choix
je suis venu sauver mon pays et les gens
que j'aime tu te crois indigne d'être
chef car tu viens de te monde
mais c'est exactement cela qui est en
rang digne
c'est une aubaine
guerre se propage de la surface
la fureur des sept mers ma compagne
est ce que tu vas n'avait pas pas se
lasser rousse irrésistible